2018 was a pretty rotten year
for stock market investors.
It's been a fairly long
bull market in America,
really, since March 2009.
What I mean by bull market is share prices
have risen pretty steadily
without a very big setback,
so share prices in America have raced
away from pretty much everywhere else.
From Europe, from Japan,
from emerging markets.
America's really been the place
where stock market
investors have wanted to be.
The questions is, is that
gonna be true in 2019?
In a market that's
coming pretty mature now,
going into it's 10th year,
is there really very much
upside from US stocks anymore?
You might want to start
looking somewhere else,
looking at Europe, looking
at emerging markets
which haven't been rising quite as quickly
and, therefore, are cheaper
and of better value.
The other way of looking
at things is to say,
if things are getting risky,
after a pretty awful year
like 2018, I might just
want to double down
on the things that have
done well for me so far.
Stick with America, stick
with technology stocks,
so-called FAANG.
That's Facebook, Apple,
Amazon, Netflix, and Google.
These are the companies
that investors think
are gonna do well, not just
for the next few years,
but for the next few decades.
The problem with that view is,
it does rely on the US economy continuing
to do better than economies elsewhere.
Most people think next
year will be a slower year
for US economic growth.
China's economy has
actually been slowing down,
and that's not just because
of Donald Trump's trade war.
There's also been an underlying slowdown
in consumer spending
in the Chinese economy,
and that hasn't just affected China.
That's affected all the local
emerging markets in Asia
and it's also affected Europe.
About a third of the profits that European
listed companies make
come either from China
or from other emerging markets
that are tied into China.
So when China slows, Europe slows as well.
The Chinese government is worried
about the degree to which
the economy has been slowing,
so it's been trying to gee
up the economy a little bit
by cutting taxes, by
relaxing monitoring policy,
and by spending more on infrastructure.
If that starts to percolate through
into the Chinese economy next year,
you could also see growth picking up
in economies that rely
heavily on Chinese demand
in Asia but also in Europe.
Half of investors think it's best to stick
with the US market, and
half of investors think
it will be better to look
elsewhere for growth.
We're looking forward here
and we don't really know
what's gonna happen in 2019.
Investors always have to
deal with uncertainty.
What's the best way to deal with that?
Well, in general, it makes sense
to try and spread your bets widely,
not to put all your eggs in one basket
as investors have been doing
with the American market.
Buy a basket of stocks
that gives you exposure
to a wide range of emerging markets,
and also a basket of stocks
that gives you exposure
to a lot of rich
economies outside America.
That's Europe and Japan and Australia.
Spread your bets is probably
the best strategy for 2019.